A quick warning, there are curse words that are unbeeped in today's episode of this show. If you prefer a beeped version, you can find that at our website, thisamericanlife.org.
先作个简短的警告，本期节目中包含未消音的脏话。如果您更喜欢消音版本，可以在我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org 上找到。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Emanuele Berry, the show's executive editor. I'm in for Ira Glass. This week's show is reported by a friend of mine, Saidu Tejan-Thomas Jr. Last spring, he gave me a call. He wanted to talk about a show idea. His big pitch-- a podcast series about activists.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》。我是本节目的执行编辑埃马纽埃尔·贝里，今天代班伊拉·格拉斯。本周的节目由我的朋友小赛杜·特詹-托马斯报道。去年春天他给我打了个电话，想谈谈一个节目构思。他的重头戏——一个关于活动人士的播客系列。
I was not into it. I had covered protests in Ferguson the year Michael Brown was shot. Spent late nights watching protesters standoff with police, weekends at marches. I know how this goes. It's always the same story-- chanting, impassioned activists talking about why they came out, hopeful, forward-looking statements. I watched as the story replicated in cities across the country with Black death after Black death.
我当时不太感兴趣。迈克尔·布朗被枪杀那年，我报道过弗格森的抗议活动。我花了无数深夜看着抗议者与警察对峙，周末也都在游行中度过。我知道这套路。总是同样的故事——喊口号，热情的活动人士讲述他们为何走上街头，说着充满希望、展望未来的话。我看着这样的故事在全国各个城市一遍又一遍地重演，伴随着一个个黑人的逝去。
Saidu and I talked for an hour. I wasn't sold. He ignored me and made the show anyway. It's a podcast called Resistance. And I cannot bear how happy me saying the next few words will make Saidu, but it's good. So he didn't make the story you'd get by going to protest after protest, like I feared. Instead, he told stories that unfold over time, about people's lives being changed by the decision to protest, what happens with their personal relationships, home life taking a backseat, exhaustion, egos, celebration, and arguments.
我和赛杜聊了一个小时。我没被说服。但他没理会我，还是把节目做出来了。这档播客叫《抵抗》。虽然赛杜听到我接下来说的话会高兴得让我受不了，但不得不说，这节目做得真好。他没有像我担心的那样，只是去参加一场又一场抗议来拼凑故事。相反，他讲述的是随着时间推移而展开的故事，关于人们如何因决定参与抗议而改变生活，关于他们的个人关系、家庭生活如何变得次要，以及随之而来的疲惫、自我膨胀、庆祝和争执。
Saidu made the story that's always been there, but no one ever tells. There's this perception of Black Lives Matter, that it's this one thing. But of course, the larger social movement of our time is really a loose collection of different groups with different personalities, goals, and methods.
赛杜挖掘出了那些一直存在却无人讲述的故事。人们对“黑人的命也是命”有一种刻板印象，认为那是一件单一的事情。但事实上，我们这个时代这场波澜壮阔的社会运动，其实是由不同团体组成的松散集合，他们有着不同的个性、目标和方法。
And Saidu made a series of stories about one of them, a group called Warriors in the Garden. It was started by about a dozen activists, mostly in their 20s, Black and Brown-- a handful of women, but mostly men. They're students, marketing directors, waiters, and models. Derrick Ingram, one of the founding members of the group, says a thing that unifies them is that each one of them is the loudest person they know.
赛杜制作了一系列关于其中一个团体的故事，他们叫“花园中的战士”。这个组织由十几个主要二十多岁的黑人和棕色人种活动人士发起，其中有少数女性，但大多数是男性。他们有的在校读书，有的是营销总监、服务员和模特。该团体的创始人之一德里克·英格拉姆说，能把他们团结在一起的原因是，他们每个人都是自己认识的人中最爱发声的那个。
Think about this. Like, I saw 5,000 people marching and I thought, I can lead them. I need to get in front. How narcissistic do you have to be to jump in front of 5,000 people and just start screaming at them? Like, I mean-- but I did it.
想想看。我看到5000人在游行，我心想，我可以带领他们。我得走到最前面。得有多自恋才敢跳到5000人面前开始对他们尖叫？我是说——但我确实做了。
All the Warriors in the Garden did it. And they found each other because they were all at the front of the marches. And very quickly, they became one of the best known groups in New York City organizing protests after the murder of George Floyd.
所有的“花园中的战士”都这么做了。他们因为都在游行队伍的最前方而相遇。很快，他们就成了纽约市在乔治·弗洛伊德遇害后组织抗议活动最出名的团体之一。
The group is cool. They look cool. And they built a huge social media following. When people showed up to their protests, they made sure they had a good time, which meant a lot of chanting and dancing and music being played. They were explicitly a nonviolent organization because they didn't want their events to feel like endless clashes with police. They wanted them to feel like celebrations.
这个团体很酷，看起来也很酷。他们在社交媒体上积累了大量粉丝。当人们来参加他们的抗议活动时，他们确保大家玩得开心，这意味着大量的喊口号、跳舞和播放音乐。他们明确表示是一个非暴力组织，因为他们不想让活动变成与警察无休止的冲突。他们希望这些活动感觉像是庆典。
Our actual marches are like club promoting. Like, we have digital campaigns. And a lot of groups don't roll like that. They make these half-assed flyers on Canva. They don't even know what their route's going to be. People are high out of their minds, screaming, tagging shit. That's not how Warriors roll. Yeah, there's a level of professionalism, joy. Not to bastardize or commercialize what we do, but people have called us the Summer Jam or Coachella of protests.
我们实际的游行就像推广夜店一样。我们有数字营销活动。很多团体不是这种路数。他们只会用 Canva 随便做些粗糙的传单，甚至连游行路线都不知道。人们醉生梦死，在那儿瞎叫唤、到处涂鸦。这不是“战士”们的风格。是的，我们有专业精神和快乐。不是为了糟蹋或商业化我们的行为，但人们曾把我们称为抗议界的“夏日音乐节”或“科切拉音乐节”。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
I'm just saying. They have! They have. They really-- I mean, multiple people. It's because it's a vibe!
我只是随口说说。他们确实这么说过！他们真的——我是说，很多人都这么说。因为这就是一种氛围！
That's Saidu laughing. And on today's show, we're going to bring you some of what he found. He got very interested in three of the Warriors in particular, three people Saidu really identified with-- men who entered the movement with similar ideas and motivations, who changed over the course of 10 months and ended up in very different places with different conclusions. But the story is not just about them. It's also about Saidu. Here he is.
那是赛杜在笑。在今天的节目中，我们将向您展示他所发现的一些内容。他对“花园中的战士”中的三个人特别感兴趣，这三个人也是赛杜真正产生共鸣的对象——他们带着相似的理念和动机加入运动，在10个月的时间里发生了改变，最终走向了截然不同的终点，有着不同的结论。但这不仅仅是关于他们的故事，也是关于赛杜的故事。他来了。
When the Warriors in the Garden and people all around the world started going outside and protesting last summer, I'm kind of ashamed to say that I was on my couch playing video games. The most I raised my voice for anything was to talk trash to my friends over a headset.
去年夏天，当“花园中的战士”和世界各地的人们开始走上街头抗议时，我感到很羞愧，因为当时我正坐在沙发上打游戏。我为任何事情发出的最大声音就是戴着耳机跟朋友互相打嘴仗。
But it was during one of these games that my boy asked me, yo, did you hear about what happened to George Floyd? I hadn't yet, but these days, your homies don't ask if you've heard what happened to a Black man you've never heard of, unless that man is already dead. And I really wasn't trying to hear that because I've been down that road before.
但在其中一场游戏里，我的兄弟问我，嘿，你听到乔治·弗洛伊德的事了吗？当时我还没听说。但如今，除非那个黑人已经死了，否则你的朋友们根本不会问你有没有听说过某个你从未耳闻的黑人的遭遇。我真的不想听这些，因为我之前已经经历过那样的路了。
Just six years ago, in 2015, when I was in college, I went to some of the first Black Lives Matter protests in my city. I remember shouting the names of Trayvon and Tamir and Sandra and Akai and countless others, until I lost my voice to tears. But it didn't stop this shit from continuing. The names still piled up. And there was nothing that told me that anything I could do would slow it down.
就在六年前，2015年，我还在上大学时，我去参加了我所在城市最早的几场“黑人的命也是命”抗议活动。我记得我一边哭喊一边呼唤着特雷冯、塔米尔、桑德拉、阿凯和无数其他人的名字，直到我哭到失声。但这些该死的事情并没有停止。名字依然在增加。没有任何迹象表明我所做的一切能减缓这一切。
My last act of resistance, the last time I thought it was worth it to engage with the death of another Black man, came three years later, in 2018, the year the police killed my friend. His name was Marcus-David Peters, the only man I ever met with two first names. We met while working together as RAs in college, and the man was so strange in all the best ways.
我的最后一次抵抗，也就是最后一次我觉得值得去面对另一个黑人死亡这件事的时刻，是在三年后的2018年，那一年警察杀死了我的朋友。他的名字叫马库斯-大卫·彼得斯，我认识的唯一一个拥有两个名字的人。我们是在大学当宿舍管理员时认识的，这个人在各个方面都非常特别。
He carried a flip phone and didn't have social media. He was the only person in the whole dorm who outfitted his windows with satin curtains, deep red. He would burn expensive candles on his kitchen counter that he probably bought from Williams-Sonoma or something like that, we worked out together at the school gym, and our whole RA staff would just fry him about how much of an old man he was-- his two tight shirts, his cheesy smile, his bald head, the way he always reminded you to carry cash for emergencies whenever you leave the house.
他用的是翻盖手机，从不玩社交媒体。他是整个宿舍里唯一一个给窗户装上深红色缎面窗帘的人。他会在厨房台面上点昂贵的蜡烛，可能是从 Williams-Sonoma 买的之类，我们常在学校健身房一起健身。我们整个宿舍管理团队总是取笑他像个老头子——他总是穿着紧身衬衫，带着俗气的笑容，留着光头，还有他总是提醒你出门时要带现金以备不时之需的习惯。
A couple of years after we graduated, Marcus stayed behind to become a high school teacher in Richmond, Virginia. He was having a mental health episode one day, when the cops showed up and murdered him, just two miles away from where we'd gone to school. His death felt like this huge weight that all of a sudden now belonged to everyone who knew him. And I didn't want it. I started doing anything I could to get rid of it.
毕业几年后，马库斯留下来在弗吉尼亚州里士满做一名高中老师。有一天，他正经历精神健康危机，警察赶到后杀了他，距离我们上学的地方仅两英里。他的死就像一块沉重的石头，突然压在了所有认识他的人身上。我不想承受这些，我开始尽一切努力想摆脱这种感觉。
So my last attempt at activism was trying to get the leadership of our university to acknowledge what Marcus meant to our community, to make a commitment that they would prevent something like this from ever happening again. I called their office and told other people to flood the phone lines, too. But then, nothing from leadership-- no statement, no acknowledgment.
所以我最后一次尝试活动，是试图让我们的大学管理层承认马库斯对我们社区的意义，并承诺他们会防止类似事件再次发生。我给他们的办公室打了电话，并叫其他人也去打爆他们的电话。但管理层没有任何回应——没有声明，没有承认。
I could have kept at it, kept pushing to make something out of this tragedy in order to feel a little lighter. I thought about flying back to Richmond and protesting, or calling up his family to ask what they wanted me to do to help to get justice for him. But the longer I waited, the more the whole thing felt so damn heavy. What am I supposed to do with this? When you become somebody who knows someone killed by police, when police violence touches your life, what do you do next?
我本可以坚持下去，继续施压，从这场悲剧中挖掘出某种意义，好让自己感觉轻松一点。我曾想过飞回里士满去抗议，或者打电话给他家人问我能做些什么来帮他伸张正义。但等待的时间越长，整件事就变得越发沉重。我该拿这事怎么办？当你成了那个认识被警察杀害的人、当警察暴力触碰到你的生活时，你下一步该做什么？
I've struggled with this question for three years, ever since Marcus died. And it's that question that drew me to the Warriors, the group of protesters that I followed for 10 months. It's that question that drew me to three men in particular who were trying to answer it.
自从马库斯去世后的三年里，我一直在这个问题中挣扎。正是这个问题把我引向了“战士”们，我追踪了他们10个月。正是这个问题把我引向了试图回答这个问题的三个人。
The first Warrior I met was a man named Chi, Chi Osse. I called him up for the first time one evening in early June, but he was busy.
我见到的第一个战士叫Chi，Chi Osse。我六月初的一天晚上第一次给他打电话，但他很忙。
Hey, Chi.
嘿，Chi。
Hey, how's it going? You're on speakerphone. I'm with my stylist, Brandon.
嘿，你好吗？在用免提，我和造型师布兰登在一起。
Hi.
你好。
You said you're with who?
你说你和谁在一起？
My stylist.
我的造型师。
Chi says he's with his stylist. I had done a little digging on social media so I knew that he was really into fashion. I also knew that he was young, 22 years old. He has somewhat of a baby face, but takes really good candid photos that make him look much older and hella confident.
Chi说他正和造型师在一起。我事先在社交媒体上搜了一下，所以知道他很注重时尚。我也知道他很年轻，才22岁。他长着一张娃娃脸，但拍出的抓拍照片让他看起来成熟得多，而且自信爆棚。
Last May was the first time Chi had ever protested. And like so many people that watched the video of George Floyd's murder, it wrecked him, and he decided he couldn't just sit at home anymore. On his Instagram, you can see how quickly he took to protesting. He went from being Chi, the fashion enthusiast, to Chi, the co-founder of Warriors in the Garden, in just a matter of days.
去年五月是Chi第一次参加抗议。和许多观看乔治·弗洛伊德遇害视频的人一样，他被摧毁了，决定再也不能坐在家里。在他的 Instagram 上，你可以看到他多么迅速地投身于抗议中。短短几天内，他就从一个时尚爱好者Chi，变成了“花园中的战士”联合创始人Chi。
The first day, I wore shorts. I brought some water and some chapstick. That's the most immature, I mean, protesting outfit you could bring.
第一天，我穿了短裤，带了点水和润唇膏。这是你能带去参加抗议最不成熟的装扮了。
But he was still so new to all this. In Chi's Instagram video from that very first day, you can hear him crying from behind the camera. And it's obvious that he did not expect things to go as far as they did.
但他对这一切还是太陌生了。在Chi第一天的 Instagram 视频里，你可以听到他在镜头后哭泣。很明显，他没料到事情会发展到那种程度。
Oh my God.
哦，天哪。
I saw a police car get burned. I was like, whoa, it's really like this. I didn't know it would get that far.
我看到警车被烧了。我就想，哇，真的会这样。我没想到会闹这么大。
By the end of that first day, what was your overwhelming feeling?
第一天结束时，你心中压倒性的感觉是什么？
So I cried that first day in the middle of the protest, but then it was like anger. I've never been so angry at police officers before, when these motherfuckers are beating us and spraying clouds of pepper spray for people frickin' chanting.
第一天抗议中途我哭了，但随后就是愤怒。我从未像现在这样对警察感到如此愤怒，这些混蛋殴打我们，对着仅仅是在喊口号的人喷胡椒喷雾。
Seeing police violence in person made Chi more determined to keep coming back to the protests. So on day two, Chi comes correct. He's looking like he's ready for battle.
亲眼目睹警察暴力让Chi下定决心继续参加抗议。所以第二天，Chi装备齐全。他看起来像是准备好去战斗了。
The next day, I was-- you know, safety glasses and covered my entire face, pants, combat boots, not for combat, but for just toe protection.
第二天，我戴上了防护眼镜，遮住了整张脸，穿了裤子、作战靴，不是为了作战，只是为了保护脚趾。
By day three, he looks like a seasoned revolutionary. He's in Times Square on a stage, holding a microphone, in the middle of a sea of people.
到了第三天，他看起来就像个久经沙场的革命者。他站在时代广场的舞台上，手里拿着麦克风，置身于人海之中。
Everybody! They're trying to strike fear in our hearts! If they do not kneel with us, they are fucking against us.
所有人！他们试图在我们的心中播下恐惧！如果他们不与我们跪在一起，他们就是他妈的与我们为敌。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼]
Don't let them break you. Be peaceful. Don't break. They want us to break. If we break, we give them what they fucking want. No justice!
别让他们击垮你。保持和平。不要崩溃。他们想要我们崩溃。如果我们崩溃了，我们就给了他们想要的东西。没有正义！
No peace!
就没有和平！
No justice!
没有正义！
No peace!
就没有和平！
The next time you went out, is that when you wore the beret?
你下次出门的时候，是戴上贝雷帽的时候吗？
The beret was day three. That was when I was finding my own, and people were listening to me, and people were recognizing me. And I was like, let's go. If we're going to do this, let's bring fashion to it, too.
贝雷帽是第三天戴的。那时候我找到了自己的状态，人们在听我说话，人们认出了我。我心想，冲吧。如果我们要这么做，那就把时尚也带进来。
So Chi was the first Warrior I started paying attention to because it's wild to see someone so good at something they just picked up yesterday. The second Warrior I noticed those first few days was Derrick Ingram. He's the one who compared the Warriors protest to Coachella. He's always out there in a tank top and leather baseball cap.
Chi是第一个引起我注意的战士，因为看到一个昨天才接触抗议的人能做得这么好，真的很疯狂。我头几天注意到的第二个战士是德里克·英格拉姆。就是那个把“战士”的抗议比作科切拉音乐节的人。他总是穿着背心，戴着皮质棒球帽。
Derrick and Chi are both queer, but unlike Chi, Derrick wasn't new to this. And honestly, I was probably drawn to Derrick because like me, he was skeptical of protesting. He tried the marching thing back in 2014 and quit when nothing much changed. He'd moved on. He was settling into New York City. He had a new apartment without roommates.
德里克和Chi都是酷儿，但与Chi不同，德里克对这一切并不陌生。说实话，我可能被德里克吸引是因为像我一样，他对抗议活动持怀疑态度。他2014年就试过游行，结果什么都没变，他就放弃了。他已经走出来了，在纽约安顿下来，有了没有室友的新公寓。
I finally saved up, got all this money, got my place in Hell's Kitchen. But this was like my party pad. Like, get to know people, go to the club, bring somebody back. Like, I thought this was going to be my summer.
我终于攒够了钱，有了钱，在西地狱区有了自己的地方。这本该是我的派对公寓。结识新朋友，去泡吧，带人回家。我以为这会是我的一夏。
But then, George Floyd was killed. And his friends pushed him to come back out and protest again. So Derrick threw himself back in. The third Warrior I started watching is a man named John Acosta. John is extremely intense, no matter what he's talking about. But it doesn't take more than a few minutes to realize he can be a real softie, too. John will tell you how much he hates white supremacy and how much he loves you, and there will be a vein popping on his forehead both times. This is John.
但后来，乔治·弗洛伊德被杀了。他的朋友们催他重新出来抗议。于是德里克又全身心投入了。我开始关注的第三个战士叫约翰·阿科斯塔。约翰非常激烈，无论他在谈论什么。但用不了几分钟你就会意识到，他其实是个彻头彻尾的软心肠。约翰会告诉你他有多痛恨白人至上主义，有多爱你，两件事说出来时他额头上的青筋都会暴起。这是约翰。
It's Black lives, baby. All day. All lives, that just sounds stupid. Of course, all lives matter, but right now, it's Black lives that are getting taken the fuck out.
是黑人的命，宝贝。全天候。所有人的命，那听起来很蠢。当然，所有人的命都重要，但现在，真正被他妈的夺走的是黑人的命。
Most of the Warriors are in their early to mid 20s. John is older. He's 32. He's got kids. He grew up in the Bronx. And up until the protest, he worked as a security guard at the World Trade Center. When Derrifck asked John if you wanted to join the Warriors--
大多数“战士”都在20出头。约翰年纪大些，32岁。他有孩子。他在布朗克斯长大。抗议活动之前，他在世界贸易中心当保安。当德里克问约翰是否想加入“战士”时——
He said, yo, you want to be a part of the Warriors? And I was like, sure, I'll be a part of that. Let's go. Fuck yeah.
他说，嘿，你想成为“战士”的一员吗？我说，当然，我加入。走吧，妈的。
Last summer, I kept coming back to see what the Warriors were up to. I'd watch them lead protests of thousands, walk for miles, shouting, "Black Lives Matter," "Hands up, don't shoot," "NYPD, suck my dick," and my personal favorite, "1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, fuck 12." I also watched as they formed bonds with each other, sleeping over each other's houses, going out for drinks. I rode along as they traveled to other cities to protest.
去年夏天，我一直回来看看“战士”们在忙什么。我看着他们带领成千上万的人游行，走上几英里，高喊“黑人的命也是命”、“举起手来，别开枪”、“纽约警察，吃我的屎”，还有我个人最喜欢的，“1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 操你妈的12（警察）”。我还看着他们互相建立羁绊，在彼此家里过夜，一起出去喝酒。我跟着他们去其他城市抗议。
When they talk about those early days, it almost sounds romantic. They use words like "fate" and "destiny" to describe meeting each other. It's low key corny, but kind of cute. The murder of George Floyd brought them together, but it also brought police into their lives in a way they'd never been faced with before. I hadn't figured out the right way to deal with the space that police violence took up in my life, but they seemed to be on a path to figuring it out for themselves.
当他们谈论起那段早期的日子时，听起来几乎很浪漫。他们用“缘分”和“宿命”来形容彼此的相遇。有点土，但很可爱。乔治·弗洛伊德的谋杀案将他们聚在一起，但也让警察以一种前所未有的方式进入了他们的生活。我还没找到处理警察暴力在我生活中所占空间的正确方法，但他们似乎正在找到属于自己的解决之道。
The Warriors were pretty successful straight out the gate. They started organizing their own huge protests. They got a ton of media attention and built a big social media following. Chi in particular became a really recognizable face in the movement. He figured out early on something that takes a lot of first-time protesters a while to come to terms with, which is that at some point, the attention will die down and the streets will clear. And then what? Just a couple of weeks in, Chi was already starting to think about the future. And then, he got a text from his auntie.
“战士”们一开始就相当成功。他们开始组织自己的大型抗议活动。他们获得了大量的媒体关注，并积累了庞大的社交媒体粉丝。Chi尤其成为了这场运动中一张非常有辨识度的面孔。他很早就想通了许多新手抗议者需要很长时间才能接受的一件事，那就是在某个时刻，关注度会减弱，街道会清空。然后呢？仅仅几周后，Chi就开始思考未来了。然后，他收到了他姨妈发来的一条短信。
Well, she was giving some critiques to my brothers and I over a group text a couple of weeks back about how young people don't know about their council members and was challenging me on all of this and that. And I didn't know, so I took it upon myself to do the research. And--
嗯，她在几周前的一个群聊里批评我和我兄弟，说年轻人不了解他们的市议员，质疑了我所有这些事情。我不知道，所以我决定自己去做调研。然后——
So he learned who his city council member is, and he also learned that that guy wouldn't be running for re-election in 2021. There was going to be an empty seat. He texted his auntie back.
于是他了解了谁是他的市议员，还了解到那个人不会在2021年竞选连任。那将是一个空缺席位。他给姨妈回了短信。
Like, hey. Well, I think I'm running for city council now.
就说，嘿，我觉得我现在要竞选市议员了。
When I heard Chi was running, I kind of wondered if he just got caught up in the moment of last summer. He's a 22-year-old. What does he know about policy, facts and figures, crafting a political message, how to reach voters?
当我听说Chi要竞选时，我有点怀疑他是不是只是被去年夏天的一时冲动冲昏了头。他才22岁。他懂什么政策、数据、政治口号的制定，以及如何争取选民？
He started bringing in the Warriors to act as his political advisors. They asked Chi about any incriminating posts he may have made on social media, debated if he should tone down his chants, the merits of his whole beret look. And then, just a few days later, on Juneteenth, Chi attended a public meeting on Zoom with a bunch of New York political heavy hitters-- the leader of the New York County Democrats, a sitting city council member, and a few other public servants who had been in the game for years. Chi took his turn to speak.
他开始请“战士”们担任他的政治顾问。他们问Chi是否有在社交媒体上发布过任何有争议的内容，辩论他是否应该降低喊口号的调门，探讨他那顶贝雷帽的价值。几天后的“六月节”，Chi在 Zoom 上参加了一场有许多纽约政界大咖出席的公开会议——纽约县民主党领袖、一位在职市议员和其他几位多年从事公职的服务人员。Chi轮到发言了。
I do applaud the passing of initiative 760-A, 721-A, and T2020-6267 yesterday, but I'm looking forward to the proposed $1 billion budget cut and the repeal of 50-A.
我确实对昨天通过的760-A、721-A和T2020-6267号提案表示赞赏，但我更期待拟议中的10亿美元预算削减和对50-A条款的废除。
I heard that, and my first reaction was like, what? What is 760-A, 721-A, 2020-626-- like, what is that? This is the moment where I was like, oh, shit, this man has been doing his homework. This isn't just about berets and looking good for him. He's actually got receipts, and he isn't afraid to show them. It was really impressive.
听到这里，我的第一反应是，什么？什么是760-A、721-A、2020-626...那是什么？那一刻我意识到，天哪，这家伙真的做了功课。对他来说，这不仅仅是戴贝雷帽和耍帅。他确实有料，而且他不怕展示出来。这真的令人印象深刻。
It's just the tip of the iceberg. I challenge you all to go further than $1 billion in NYPD budget cuts. I challenge you to go further in passing legislation that prevents police brutality and systemic racism within policing.
这只是冰山一角。我向你们所有人挑战，要在削减纽约警局预算上做得比10亿美元更多。我挑战你们在通过防止警察暴行和警务系统中系统性种族主义的立法方面走得更远。
He caps it off with this.
他以此作为结尾。
Also, I'm announcing my campaign for city council, district 36, 2021, Chi Osse.
另外，我宣布参加2021年第36选区市议员竞选，我是Chi Osse。
Thank you so much, Chi.
非常感谢你，Chi。
We really, really appreciate you being here.
我们真的非常感谢你的到来。
By June, the Warriors had a political candidate. By July, they applied for nonprofit status so their work could extend beyond the protests. And in August, in response to their activism and protests throughout New York, Governor Andrew Cuomo repealed 50-A. It gave the public open access to police disciplinary records for the first time in nearly 40 years. This is the kind of legislative victory that Chi wants to secure for the movement by running for office. But he is still a Warrior, which means he's still out in the streets with the rest of the group.
到了六月，“战士”们有了自己的政治候选人。到了七月，他们申请了非营利组织身份，以便他们的工作可以超出抗议范畴。八月，为了回应他们在纽约各地的活动和抗议，安德鲁·科莫州长废除了50-A条款。这让公众近40年来首次可以公开查阅警察的纪律记录。这就是Chi通过竞选公职想为运动争取的立法胜利。但他仍然是一个“战士”，这意味着他仍然和团队里的其他人一起在街头奔走。
Being Black and choosing to fight for justice is like putting a second target on your back-- the first you're born with, the second you're literally volunteering for. All summer, I watched protesters being tear gassed, kettled, and beaten by cops. The cops were so persistently violent that the state attorney general would later sue the NYPD for, quote, "pattern of using excessive force and making false arrests against New Yorkers during peaceful protests."
身为黑人并选择为正义而战，就像在背上贴了第二个靶子——第一个靶子是你与生俱来的，第二个则是你主动选择的。整个夏天，我都在看着抗议者被警察喷催泪瓦斯、围困和殴打。警察的暴力行为如此持续，以至于州检察长后来起诉了纽约警局，指控其“在和平抗议期间对纽约人使用过度武力和进行虚假逮捕的模式”。
The Warriors were already mostly Black. They already had that first target. They were about to find out what exactly that second target could look like. One Thursday night in August, Kiara, one of the Warriors, along with Derrick, decided to go out for drinks.
“战士”们本来就大多是黑人。他们本来就有第一个靶子。他们即将发现第二个靶子到底是什么样子。八月的一个周四晚上，Kiara 和德里克决定出去喝酒。
We were drinking. We were dancing. We were singing. It just felt like it was fun.
我们在喝酒，我们在跳舞，我们在唱歌。感觉很开心。
I had a couple of shots, and I had two or three of those. And I was slammed-- slammed! Having fun. Like, we were just hanging out outside. We were having a blast.
我喝了几杯，可能两三杯吧。我被灌醉了——彻底醉了！玩得很开心。我们就挂在外面，玩疯了。
Around 2:00 AM, Kiara and Derrick and a few of the other Warriors split up from the bar and made their way home. Derrick told me that he drank so much that night that when he got home, he tried to cook a whole steak at 3:00 in the morning, which-- who can't relate? He didn't end up going to bed till around 4:00.
凌晨2点左右，Kiara 和德里克以及其他几个“战士”从酒吧分开，各自回家。德里克告诉我，那天晚上他喝得太多，以至于到家后，他在凌晨3点试图煎一整块牛排，这谁没体会过呢？他最后大概凌晨4点才睡。
What do you hear at 7:15?
7点15分你听到了什么？
A knock at the door. Boom, boom, boom.
敲门声。砰，砰，砰。
Derrick drags himself out of bed to go see who it is.
德里克挣扎着起床去看看是谁。
I have the deadbolt chain on. I looked through my peephole-- short white guy. He asked the address, and I told him my address. And then he asked my name, and I told him my name. And he was like, I have a warrant for your arrest.
我挂着防盗链。我通过猫眼往外看——是个矮个子白人。他问地址，我告诉了他我的地址。然后他问我的名字，我告诉了他。他说，我有一张逮捕你的令状。
It was the police. Derrick had no idea what this was about. He asked the cop to slide the warrant under the door. He looks down, but he doesn't see anything. He didn't know what to do. So he alerts the rest of the Warriors in their group chat that the cops are outside of his door. And pretty soon, all the Warriors are awake and alarmed. A lot of them start checking their own windows and looking through peepholes to see if cops are at their houses, too.
是警察。德里克根本不知道这事关什么。他让警察把令状从门下塞进来。他往下看，什么都没看见。他不知道该怎么办。于是他在群聊里提醒其他“战士”警察在他门口。很快，所有的“战士”都醒了过来并感到惊恐。许多人开始检查自己的窗户，透过猫眼看警察是不是也到了他们家。
I was scared for him. I was scared for myself.
我为他担心。我为自己担心。
Are they coming to my house next?
他们接下来会来我家吗？
Are they going to knock on my door?
他们会敲我的门吗？
Like, how is this going to end?
这一切会怎么结束？
When the rest of the Warriors don't see cops at their doors, they start strategizing about how to help Derrick. Some of them want to head to his apartment ASAP. But others say, no, what if the cops are expecting us to do that? And once we show up, they just arrest everybody? Then Chi comes up with another idea.
当其他“战士”发现家门口没有警察时，他们开始策划如何帮助德里克。有些人想尽快赶到他的公寓。但另一些人说，不，万一警察就是等着我们去呢？等我们一到，他们就把所有人抓起来？然后Chi想到了另一个主意。
Chi instantly was like, "Go live, go live, go live, go live."
Chi立刻说，“开直播，开直播，开直播，开直播。”
Everybody said, go live.
大家都说，开直播。
Document that shit. I mean, if they're banging on your door, lying about a warrant, people need to see it.
把那些混蛋记录下来。我是说，如果他们在敲你的门，对令状撒谎，人们需要看到它。
The Warriors had been amassing a huge social media following all summer. Before, it was basically just a tool to keep young people engaged in the movement. But now, they were telling Derrick to go live to their 40,000 followers in hopes that it would keep him safe.
整个夏天，“战士”们积累了大量社交媒体粉丝。之前，这基本上只是一个让年轻人参与运动的工具。但现在，他们告诉德里克对4万名粉丝进行直播，希望能保护他安全。
I don't know what the fuck is going on. Honestly, I have no idea what I did. So, this is crazy.
我不知道到底发生了什么他妈的事情。说实话，我不知道我做了什么。这太疯狂了。
In the video, Derrick is wearing the same clothes he wore out drinking the night before-- a leather baseball cap, a navy blue button down, and a silver ring that shines whenever he touches his face, trying to figure out what to do. In the comments, Derrick's friends tell him to go back to the door and ask for the warrant again.
在视频中，德里克穿着昨晚出去喝酒时穿的同一套衣服——皮质棒球帽、深蓝色纽扣衬衫，摸脸时那枚银戒指闪闪发光，他正试图弄清楚该怎么办。在评论区，德里克的朋友们让他回到门口再次要求查看令状。
Officer?
警官？
Yes, sir.
是的，先生。
What's going on? Did you have the warrant?
发生了什么？你有令状吗？
There's probable cause to arrest you right now.
现在有合理的理由逮捕你。
Is there a reason they haven't called me about this investigation? Is it active?
他们没有就这项调查联系过我吗？这是正在进行的吗？
It's active, yes. For assault.
是正在进行的，是的。因为袭击罪。
The cop says yes, it's active. It's for an assault.
警察说是的，是正在进行的。是因为袭击罪。
OK.
好。
That's why I'm here.
这就是我在这儿的原因。
To detain me?
要拘留我吗？
You will be arrested, yes.
你会因被捕而受拘留，是的。
Oh, Jesus. So there's that.
哦，耶稣。所以就是这样。
Sitting back down in front of the camera, Derrick takes the cap off a gallon of water and starts chugging it. He doesn't know why the cops are here. He wonders if this has to do with a complaint he filed against the police a few weeks back. Was this retaliation or something? He's not sure. An hour passes.
德里克在摄像机前坐回原位，打开一加仑水瓶的盖子开始猛灌。他不知道警察为什么会在这里。他想知道这是否与他几周前针对警察提出的投诉有关。这是报复吗？他不确定。一个小时过去了。
So, I get a message saying that, yo, there's a bunch of fucking cops up in front of fucking Derrick's crib. And I was like, what?
然后，我收到消息说，嘿，德里克家门前有一群他妈的警察。我说，什么？
John immediately hopped on his bike and flew over to Hell's Kitchen, Manhattan, as fast as possible. It's not unusual for cops to show up to arrest someone without a warrant. What is unusual, though, is what John saw outside Derrick's apartment that day. It wasn't just like one or two cops in a patrol car at Derrick's. It looked like a full-on tactical operation-- large NYPD trucks, men in suits going in and out of the building, a battering ram. They'd even begun closing off the block with barricades.
约翰立刻跳上自行车，以最快的速度飞奔到曼哈顿的西地狱区。警察不带令状就来抓人并不罕见。但罕见的是约翰那天在德里克公寓外看到的情景。那不是一两辆巡逻车在德里克家门口那么简单。那看起来像是一场全面的战术行动——大型纽约警局卡车，身着制服的人员进进出出，还有撞门锤。他们甚至开始用路障封闭街区。
So I get there. I'm rolling up. I'm like, what the fuck? Yo, to see all those officers outside, bro, was intense. What I saw that kind of baffled me, that let me know that, oh, shit, they're treating him like a terrorist, was when I seen the canines. When I seen the dogs, I say, they got him like he's a fucking terrorist.
我到了。我骑着车过去。我想，这他妈是怎么回事？嘿，看到那么多警官在外面，兄弟，太紧张了。我所看到的让我困惑，让我意识到，噢，糟糕，他们把他当作恐怖分子来对待，是我看到警犬的时候。看到狗时，我说，他们把他像对待他妈的恐怖分子一样对待。
For all his intense energy, all John can really do at this point is be a witness. So he stays out there on his bike. Back inside, Derrick realizes he's surrounded.
尽管他性格火爆，约翰现在能做的也只是做个目击者。于是他骑着车待在那里。而在公寓里，德里克意识到自己被包围了。
So, y'all, officers in the hallway, officers with guns, officer in empty apartments in the building across from me. They're banging on my door. They're literally peeking in my curtains. I had to put up a sheet. Like, there's over 30 officers here.
大家，走廊里有警官，有拿枪的警官，我对面那栋空公寓里也有警官。他们在敲我的门。他们真的在偷看我的窗帘。我不得不贴上一张床单。有超过30名警官在这里。
At this point, Derrick starts thinking about his parents. They don't even know what's going on. So he calls his dad.
这时，德里克开始想到他的父母。他们甚至不知道发生了什么。于是他给爸爸打了视频电话。
And I Facetime my dad because he doesn't know how to use IG. His first reaction was, call the cops. I was like, are you serious right now? I was like, you want me to call the police on the police? What are they going to do? Like, he was deadass. He was like, no, bring a captain out. I was like, nah, that's not going to work, man.
我跟爸爸开视频，因为他不会用 Instagram。他的第一反应是，报警。我心想，你是认真的吗？我说，你想让我向警察报警？他们能做什么？他很严肃地说，不，把队长叫出来。我说，不，那行不通的，老爸。
Oh, man, that's really interesting because--
哦，伙计，这太有趣了，因为——
My parents are--
我父母是——
But that's what parents tell you to do. You know what I'm saying? Like, wait, something bad is happening? Call the cops.
但这正是父母会告诉你去做的。你知道我的意思吗？比如，等一下，发生了糟糕的事情？报警。
I'm like, yep. And I'm showing my dad, like, yep, there's three out of my window right now, one on my balcony, a couple in the building across the street. He's like, oh my god.
我说，是的。我给爸爸看，是的，我的窗外现在有三个，阳台上有一个，对面楼里还有几个。他说，哦，天哪。
Derrick's friends kept telling him not to open the door. But the Warriors didn't really have that many other options.
德里克的朋友一直告诉他不要开门。但“战士”们真的没有太多其他选择。
I didn't know what to do at that point. So I felt like I can get riddled with bullets if I open this fucking door, but I was thinking about, fuck it, I'm going to put my body on the line. It's going to make a difference. I'm just going to open this door. If they fuck me up, that was a thought, too. Like--
那一刻我不知道该怎么办。我觉得如果我开了这该死的门，我可能会被子弹打成筛子，但我心想，去他的，我要把自己的身体放在那儿。这会有所作为的。我就要开门。如果他们弄死我，这也是一种想法。比如——
The thought of dying for the cause.
为事业而死的想法。
Yeah, the thought of dying or getting hurt was definitely a thought briefly.
是的，死或受伤的想法确实短暂地闪过。
Wow. Where do you think that came from?
哇。你觉得那想法是从哪儿来的？
Thaddeus.
撒迪厄斯。
Thaddeus McCarroll was Derrick's childhood friend. They went to school in St. Louis and would run around church camp, playing pranks together. Derrick and Thaddeus lost touch for a while, but linked up years later after high school. It was 2014, the same year Michael Brown was killed by police in Ferguson, not too far from where they grew up. That's when Derrick went to his first protests.
撒迪厄斯·麦卡罗尔是德里克儿时的朋友。他们在圣路易斯一起上学，在教堂夏令营里跑来跑去搞恶作剧。德里克和撒迪厄斯后来失联了一段时间，高中后又联系上了。那是2014年，迈克尔·布朗在弗格森被警察杀害的同一年，离他们长大的地方不远。那就是德里克第一次参加抗议的时候。
And Thaddeus was with me there the whole time. Unfortunately, he was struggling with mental illness.
撒迪厄斯一直在那儿陪着我。不幸的是，他当时正在与精神疾病斗争。
Almost a year after the Ferguson protests, in 2015, Thaddeus was at home when he started having an episode. He locked himself in his house with a knife, so Thaddeus's mom did what Derrick's dad had suggested-- she called the cops. After a long standoff, Thaddeus opened the door.
在弗格森抗议近一年后的2015年，撒迪厄斯在家时开始发病。他拿着刀把自己锁在屋里，于是撒迪厄斯的妈妈做了德里克的爸爸建议的事——她报了警。经过长时间的对峙，撒迪厄斯打开了门。
And he came storming outside, and he was shot several times, riddled with bullets. And that's how I felt. I felt like I was barricaded in here. And if I surrendered, that I could have met that same fate.
然后他冲了出来，他被开了好几枪，浑身是弹孔。这就是我的感觉。我觉得自己被困在这里了。如果我投降，我也可能遭遇同样的命运。
Thaddeus died. It's messed up to feel a kinship to somebody in this way, to know that y'all are part of some depressing brotherhood of people whose friends were killed by police. And I didn't have to be trapped in a room and get threatened by cops to identify with the thing that Derrick is feeling now-- that he might be next. It's a thought that I've had many times since Marcus was killed. But I always talk myself down. Like, there's no way something like that could happen twice in one friendship. But here was Derrick in that exact scenario.
撒迪厄斯死了。以这种方式与某人产生共鸣、知道你们都是一群朋友被警察杀死的人组成的压抑兄弟会的一员，这种感觉很糟糕。我不需要被困在屋里受到警察威胁，就能对德里克现在的感受产生共鸣——他也可能是下一个。自从马库斯被杀后，这种想法我出现过很多次。但我总是说服自己打消这个念头。比如，不可能在一段友谊里发生两次这种事。但在这里，德里克正处于完全一样的情境中。
3 and 1/2 hours in, the cops have officially closed off Derrick's street on both sides. So anyone else who wants to come and try and help is going to have a hard time. So Chi comes up with a new plan. He gets on the next train to Derrick's apartment, and when he gets off at the stop, he ducks into a nearby corner store and buys a jug of milk. When he gets to Derrick's block, he walks up to the cops at the barricade.
3个半小时后，警察已经正式封锁了德里克街道的两端。所以任何想过来帮忙的人都会遇到困难。于是Chi想到了一个新计划。他坐上下一班火车赶往德里克的公寓，下车后他躲进一家附近的便利店买了一桶牛奶。当他到达德里克的街区时，他走到封锁线上的警察面前。
I said, what's going on here? They're like, there's an incident over here. We're closing the street off. So I was like, I'm subletting at 146, right over there. I have my milk. I don't want it to get spoiled. And they were like, sorry, sir. Blah, blah, blah. And then I dropped my milk.
我说，这里发生了什么？他们说，这儿有个事件。我们要封锁这条街。所以我说，我住在这里146号。我有牛奶，我不想它变质。他们说，对不起，先生。巴拉巴拉。然后我故意弄掉了牛奶。
His plan fails, but across the street from Derrick's apartment, a small group of protesters have started to gather in a park. Chi runs over and joins them. Back inside, Derrick is on the phone with a lawyer, and things start to get even more intense.
他的计划失败了，但在德里克公寓街对面，一小群抗议者开始在公园聚集。Chi跑过去加入了他们。公寓里，德里克正跟律师通电话，事情开始变得更加紧张。
They literally cover my peephole. They had a battering ram, so all of this stuff on my wall is falling. I heard a pop, pop, pop.
他们真的盖住了我的猫眼。他们有撞门锤，所以我墙上所有的东西都在掉落。我听到砰，砰，砰。
[BATTERING]
[碰撞声]
Derrick, you're the one making this difficult. We're just trying to get you to come outside. Derrick, do you understand what I'm saying?
德里克，是你让事情变得困难的。我们只是想让你出来。德里克，你明白我在说什么吗？
Bro, this is--
兄弟，这是——
There's no hostility. You're the one being hostile right now.
没有敌意。现在是你在表现得有敌意。
I'm not being hostile. I'm calm. I'm calm. I am chill.
我没有表现得有敌意。我很冷静。我很冷静。我非常放松。
I'm sorry, I think I lost you. Um, hey, Derrick--
对不起，我想我失去你了。嗯，嘿，德里克——
There's no warrant.
根本没有令状。
And then at another point-- and this was caught on camera-- they were like--
然后在另一个时刻——这是被摄像头捕捉到的——他们说——
So why don't you be the warrior you state you are and come out and let's face the situation?
那你为什么不成为你所说的战士，出来面对这种情况呢？
--why don't you be the warrior you say you are?
——你为什么不成为你所说的战士呢？
[KNOCKING]
[敲门声]
Derrick only has two options-- stay inside or open the door. And as the police ramp up the pressure, it's getting harder and harder to know which one to choose. The lawyers he's on the phone with have been trying to negotiate a peaceful surrender with the police, but haven't had any luck. So now they're just trying to help Derrick stay calm.
德里克只有两个选择——待在里面还是开门。随着警察增加压力，越来越难知道该选哪一个。他正在通话的律师一直试图与警察协商和平投降，但没有成功。所以现在他们只是试图帮德里克保持冷静。
There's a lot going on.
发生了很多事情。
[KNOCKING]
[敲门声]
Yes, yeah, I'll--
是的，好的，我会——
Did you hear what I said, Derrick?
你听到我说的了吗，德里克？
Derrick--
德里克——
Now could you acknowledge me, please? I'm treating you like a gentleman.
现在能回应我一下吗，请。我把你当成绅士对待。
OK, I'm so overwhelmed.
好的，我太不知所措了。
Right? I'm treating you like a gentleman.
对吧？我把你当成绅士对待。
I just want to get this over with, and it's too much. It's too much.
我只想结束这一切，但这太多了。这太多了。
No, I hear you. I hear you.
不，我听到了。我听到了。
By noon, almost five hours into this whole ordeal, the crowd of supporters is getting bigger. A couple hundred people have tuned into the Instagram Live to watch. And at this point, Chi is pissed. He and the rest of the Warriors realize that what they have to do now is start putting as much pressure on the NYPD outside as they're putting on Derrick inside. So Chi grabs his megaphone and gets to work.
到了中午，整场折磨快五个小时了，支持者的人群越来越大。几百人接入了 Instagram 直播观看。这一刻，Chi被激怒了。他和“战士”们的其他人意识到，他们现在必须像警察在里面给德里克施压一样，开始给外面的纽约警局施压。于是Chi拿起扩音器开始工作。
If there was a reason for his arrest, they would have arrested him by now. It's been five hours. Where's the warrant? Where's the warrant? Where's your warrant? Where's your warrant?
如果他有被捕的理由，他们早就逮捕他了。已经五个小时了。令状在哪儿？令状在哪儿？你们的令状在哪儿？你们的令状在哪儿？
And then at one point, I could hear my friends, I could hear some of the protesters chanting from my windows. "Where's the warrant?"
然后在某个时刻，我能听到我的朋友，我能听到一些抗议者从我的窗外高喊。“令状在哪儿？”
Where's your warrant? Where's your warrant?
你们的令状在哪儿？你们的令状在哪儿？
And it was Chi.
那是Chi。
Where's your warrant?
你们的令状在哪儿？
I felt protected because there were so many eyes on me. I felt like, they're not going to kill me on live. They might hurt me. They might do some fucked up shit, but I feel protected. Like, that's how I felt.
我感到被保护了，因为有那么多双眼睛盯着我。我觉得，他们不会在直播时杀了我。他们可能会伤害我。他们可能会干些坏事，但我感到被保护了。这就是我的感觉。
This was wild to me, because cops killed people in front of an audience all the time. But Derrick felt comforted knowing that his friends were outside. So finally, he decides to open the door.
这对我来说很狂野，因为警察经常在众目睽睽之下杀人。但德里克知道朋友们在外面，感到安慰。终于，他决定开门。
I literally had my hands on the door, and I see a message. Says, don't open it, DWRECK. Don't open the door. They're leaving. I hear cheering outside.
我的手确实放在门上了，然后我看到一条消息。写着，别开门，德里克。别开门。他们要走了。我听到外面在欢呼。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
I was like, oh, shit, they are leaving. So I didn't open the door.
我心想，哦，该死，他们真的要走了。所以我没开门。
With no warning, no obvious reason, and almost as quickly as they'd shown up, the cops had packed up their stuff and bounced, just like that, after more than six hours. The moment the police left, John took off towards Derrick's building.
毫无预兆，没有明显的理由，警察出现得有多快，撤退得就有多快，就这样，在持续了六个多小时后。警察离开的那一刻，约翰冲向德里克的楼房。
That was a good moment, man. I'd seen him, he'd seen me. He'd seen that it was somebody that loves him that was there. It wasn't some fucking cop ready to take him out and shit.
那是一个美好的时刻，伙计。我看到了他，他也看到了我。他看到了这里有爱他的人。不是什么他妈的警察准备带走他之类。
Did you just hug him?
你刚才抱他了吗？
Hell yeah, man. I hugged the shit out of that man. I'm proud of that man, yo!
当然抱了，伙计。我狠狠地抱了那个男人。我为他感到自豪，兄弟！
The people united will never be defeated. The people united--
团结的人民永不被击败。团结的人民——
The next day, Derrick went with his lawyer to turn himself in at the precinct. They figured he'd be safer that way so something like this wouldn't happen again. And that's when he found out the charges against him-- assault of a police officer for allegedly shouting into a cop's ear with a megaphone at a protest. They also charged him with obstructing governmental administration, which basically means getting in the way of a cop doing their job.
第二天，德里克带着律师去警察局自首。他们觉得这样更安全，以免类似的事情再次发生。就在那时，他知道了针对他的指控——因涉嫌在抗议中用扩音器对着警察耳朵大喊，被控袭击警察。他们还指控他妨碍公务，这基本上意味着阻碍警察履行职责。
I tried to get more information from the NYPD about why all this happened, but they wouldn't tell me anything other than a generic statement, saying a police officer had tried to stop Derrick from entering a, quote, "frozen zone" at a protest, and, quote, "a struggle ensued." I'm not sure that explains deploying the full force of one of the most militarized police departments in the country for one man for six hours.
我试图从纽约警局获得更多关于这件事为何发生的信息，但他们除了一个通用的声明外什么都不肯告诉，声明称一名警察试图阻止德里克进入抗议活动的所谓“冻结区”，随后“发生了冲突”。我不确定这能解释为何为一个男人部署了该国最军事化的警察部队之一，并持续了六个小时。
I couldn't think of any justification other than they wanted to intimidate Derrick and the growing movement against police violence. Derrick was shook. But he told me after the whole thing, he also felt pretty victorious. He had been able to capture the police abusing their power to intimidate an unarmed Black person.
我想不出任何理由，除了他们想恐吓德里克和日益壮大的反警察暴力运动。德里克被吓坏了。但他事后告诉我，他也感到相当胜利。他能够捕捉到警察滥用职权恐吓手无寸铁的黑人。
Literally, that's what this whole movement is about. And that's what they did to me, publicly, in Hell's Kitchen in Manhattan. It made them look savage.
从字面上看，这就是整场运动的意义所在。这就是他们在曼哈顿西地狱区公开对我做的事。这让他们看起来像个野蛮人。
Derrick did have a second target on his back. He was Black, and now he was a prominent enough activist for the NYPD to come after him. But the Warriors' tactics, the thing they'd been doing all summer, made him safer. They won.
德里克的背上确实贴了第二个靶子。他是黑人，现在他是一个足够著名的活动人士，以至于纽约警局对他下手了。但“战士”们的策略，他们整个夏天一直在做的事，让他更安全了。他们赢了。
A little while later, I was talking to John on the phone about that day at Derrick's. He mentioned that he got a message from an anonymous account on Instagram. He hadn't noticed it at the time when he was focused on the cops. But later on--
过了一会儿，我在电话里跟约翰聊起德里克公寓那天的事。他提到他收到了 Instagram 上一个匿名账号的消息。他在关注警察时没注意到。但后来——
And as I'm looking, I'm like, what the hell is this? I open it, and it says, "You are next." I was like, what the fuck? Like, this is a threat.
我看着消息，心想，这他妈是什么？我打开它，上面写着，“你是下一个”。心想，这他妈是什么？这是威胁。
John laughed it off. He sent the guy an emoji of a middle finger and a message-- "You'll have to catch me first."
约翰把它当个笑话处理了。他发给那人一个中指表情符号和一条消息——“你得先抓到我再说”。
Coming up after the break, revenge. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
中场休息后，复仇。更多内容，稍后从芝加哥公共广播电台继续节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Emanuele Berry, sitting in for Ira today. Today on our show, Saidu Tejan-Thomas Jr. is telling the story of three activists in the group Warriors in the Garden, who, like Saidu, are trying to make sense of the question, what do you do when police violence finds you unwittingly? When we left before the break, the Warriors' activism had started to draw the attention of police. Here's Saidu again.
这里是《美国生活》。我是埃马纽埃尔·贝里，今天代伊拉主持。在今天的节目中，小赛杜·特詹-托马斯讲述了“花园中的战士”团体中三位活动人士的故事，他们和赛杜一样，试图理清这个问题：当警察暴力莫名其妙地找上你时，你该怎么办？休息前我们说到，“战士”们的活动开始引起警方的注意。下面继续由赛杜讲述。
By the end of last summer, almost all the Warriors said they'd gotten death threats on social media, all except John. John got his first one that day outside Derrick's apartment, when he was watching the police siege. He got in a message from an anonymous account on Instagram, saying, "You are next."
去年夏天快结束时，几乎所有的“战士”都说他们在社交媒体上收到过死亡威胁，除了约翰。约翰第一次收到威胁就是在那天德里克公寓外，他看着警察围困的时候。他收到一条 Instagram 匿名账号发来的消息，说“你是下一个”。
I didn't really pay any mind to it like that because-- I asked people, because this is my first threat. I asked people. I was like, yo, I just got threatened. This is my first threat. What should I do? Oh, ignore it. I have so many. And I said, all right, I'm not going to be worried about it, you know? But I'm going to be wary. I'm going to be looking around, making sure everything's OK. And then, boom. Then I got caught with my pants down.
我并没有太放在心上，因为——我问过别人，因为这是我第一次收到威胁。我问别人，嘿，我刚受到威胁。这是第一次。我该怎么办？哦，忽略它。我有过很多次。我说，好吧，我不会担心，你知道的。但我会保持警惕。我会四处看看，确保一切安好。然后，砰。我这就被打了个措手不及。
Within two weeks of the siege at Derrick's, John got on Instagram Live. He was holding up bloody wrists to the camera.
在德里克公寓围困事件的两周内，约翰开了 Instagram 直播。他对着镜头举起鲜血淋漓的手腕。
Hey, what's up, everyone? I just got hit by a car. I'm 100% sure they just-- they tried to kill me. They hit me and they booked it out of there.
嘿，大家好。我刚被车撞了。我百分之百肯定他们试图杀了我。他们撞了我，然后就逃之夭夭了。
He pans the camera to show a couple of nasty scrapes on both his legs. He was riding his bike when he got hit. I can tell John is shaken up, as he tells the people watching what just happened.
他移动镜头展示了双腿上几处严重的擦伤。他骑自行车时被撞的。我能感觉到约翰心有余悸，他讲述着刚才发生的事。
I'm moving out of his way. I'm moving more to my lane, and he just jumps the line and hits me, looks back, and then bounces. The man sees me. It's like he seen me. Clear-- I'm wearing fucking red. What the fuck? It's mad lit out here.
我从他旁边移开。我移向自己的车道，他突然变道撞向我，回头看了一眼，然后跑了。那家伙看见我了。就像他确实看见我了。清楚得很——我穿着红衣服。他妈的怎么回事？外面很亮啊。
John says he looked up at the car as it drove away. A Chevy Impala. Chevy Impalas are the kind of cars the cops are known to drive when they're undercover.
约翰说他抬头看了一眼汽车离去。一辆雪佛兰 Impala。雪佛兰 Impala 是警察便衣巡逻时常用的车型。
Shit, man. I don't even know what to really think right now. I just wanted to let y'all know because this is some crazy shit right now. I can't even call the fucking police because they're not going to do shit. Fuck 12. So I don't know if there's a way that I can prove that it was them. I'm looking for some cameras, but anybody that's out here in these streets, man, just be careful.
该死，伙计。我现在甚至不知道该想什么。我只是想让你们知道，因为这太疯狂了。我甚至不能报警，因为他们根本不会做任何事。去他的警察。所以不知道有没有办法证明是他们干的。我在找监控摄像头，但任何在街上的人，伙计，一定要小心。
With protesting, Chi, Derrick, and John have all faced off with police. But John has spent years dealing with cops threatening his life. He grew up in the Bronx, where cops are notorious for harassing the Black and Brown people who live there. When he was a kid, John says cops showed up to his house and pulled a gun out on him and his mom in their home. They were looking for somebody else. Later, in high school, he and his friends were celebrating graduation at one of their houses. He says the cops showed up then, too, kicked down the door, and pointed guns at them.
通过抗议，Chi、德里克和约翰都曾与警察对峙。但约翰多年来一直应对警察对其生命的威胁。他在布朗克斯长大，那里警察骚扰黑人和棕色人种臭名昭著。约翰说，他小时候警察曾到他家，在家里用枪指着他和妈妈。他们当时在找别人。后来，高中毕业时，他和朋友们在其中一家庆祝。他说警察也去了那里，踹开门，拿枪指着他们。
John joined the Warriors because they were the community he'd been looking for, the people who would help them fight back against this enemy that loomed large over his life long before last summer. But when he got hit by the Impala, something started to switch for John. I called him up a few days later.
约翰加入“战士”是因为他们是他一直在寻找的社区，人们会帮他们反击这个早在去年夏天之前就笼罩在他生命中的敌人。但当他被 Impala 撞倒后，约翰的某些东西开始转变。几天后我给他打了电话。
This shit changes everything. Cops did this shit to me. That's what I believe, because it was a fucking Impala. These motherfuckers tried to take me away from my family, man. All I want now, I want revenge.
这该死的一切改变了一切。是警察对我干的。我相信是这样，因为那是一辆 Impala。这些混蛋试图把我和家人分开。我现在想要的只有复仇。
This was the first time I had heard any Warrior talk about vengeance. They talked about not backing down, about marching until they could secure some real wins for the movement in New York City, but never in the context of revenge. The Warriors were deeply committed to nonviolence, and John was committed to the Warriors, so he'd agreed to that, too. But after the hit and run, he was questioning everything.
这是我第一次听到有“战士”谈论报复。他们谈论永不退缩，谈论游行直到在纽约市为运动赢得真正的胜利，但从未在复仇的语境下讨论。他们深信非暴力，“战士”们也都如此，所以约翰也同意。但在那次肇事逃逸后，他开始质疑一切。
You think I give a fuck about some peaceful protest now? Nah, man. I didn't do shit, bro. Every single time one of these motherfuckers is in my face, doing some bullshit, I don't knock them out. I don't kick them in the dick. I don't kick them in the knee. I don't kick them in the face. I don't do any-- I just go, aight, that's cool. And I take the high road. This was an attempt on my life, man. I'm not going around sleeping anymore. Like, that shit woke me the fuck up. It woke me the fuck up.
你觉得我现在还他妈在乎什么和平抗议吗？不，伙计。我什么都没做，兄弟。每次这些混蛋面对我、做些破事时，我都没有打倒他们。我没有踢他们裆部。我没有踢他们膝盖。我没有踢他们脸。我什么都没做——我只是说，好吧，没关系。然后我采取了高姿态。这是一次针对我生命的企图，伙计。我再也睡不着了。这事儿彻底把我惊醒了。彻彻底底。
I have no way of knowing if the car that hit John was an undercover cop. The NYPD did not respond to our questions about this incident. But John didn't want to take any more chances. He told me he tried to get security camera footage from a nearby business to try and prove that it was a cop who hit him. But he says they wouldn't give it to him. So now he just doesn't leave the house without strapping a GoPro camera to his chest so he can review his own footage every night when he comes home.
我无法确定撞约翰的车是否是便衣警察。纽约警局没有回应我们就此事件提出的问题。但约翰不想再冒任何险。他告诉我，他试图获取附近商家的安全监控录像以证明是警察撞了他。但他说他们不给。所以现在，他如果不胸前绑上 GoPro 摄像机绝不出门，这样他每晚回家都能查看自己的录像。
He admitted he was paranoid, but I understood where he was coming from. He just watched his friend be trapped in his apartment for six hours by the NYPD. If Derrick wasn't on Instagram Live the whole time, who would have believed the shit they pulled? John didn't have evidence. He just had his word and plenty of examples to point to of police forces surveilling, harassing, or killing Black leaders. MLK, Fred Hampton, Nina Simone, Malcolm X-- the list goes on. John told me he started pulling away from the Warriors. The protests with all the singing and dancing just didn't seem right. It felt too much like a parade, instead of a protest.
他承认自己有被害妄想，但我理解他的感受。他刚看着朋友被纽约警局困在公寓里六个小时。如果德里克没全程开启 Instagram 直播，谁会相信他们搞的那一套？约翰没有证据。他只有自己的一面之词，以及警察监视、骚扰或杀害黑人领袖的众多例子。马丁·路德·金、弗雷德·汉普顿、尼娜·西蒙、马尔科姆·X——名单不胜枚举。约翰告诉我，他开始从“战士”中撤出。那些又唱又跳的抗议看起来一点都不对劲。看起来更像是游行，而不是抗议。
I love it when they're happy. I do, man. It makes me happy, too, man. But we just have no time for that. And when I seen them, I just feel like they're losing sight of what's going on. I've been thinking about that solid, like solid. All this bull, and we out here giving out Black joy. I was fine with it for a little bit. Then I started to realize, yo, what the fuck is going on? I looked at myself. I'm like, where the fuck is the rage, bro? I'm not feeling this no more.
当他们开心时我很高兴。真的，伙计。那也让我开心。但我们没时间搞这个。看到他们时，我觉得他们忽视了正在发生的事情。我一直在深刻思考这一点。所有这些废话，我们却在这里分发“黑人的快乐”。我有一阵子还能接受。然后我开始意识到，嘿，这他妈是怎么回事？我审视自己。我在想，愤怒去哪儿了，兄弟？我再也感觉不到那个了。
The Warrior stance is that Black joy, that celebrating in Black life in spite of everything that's trying to keep you down, is a radical form of protest. You take up space in the streets. You dance and chant unapologetically. But you don't engage with the police. You keep it moving. But John didn't want to hear that anymore.
“战士”的立场是，“黑人的快乐”，即在试图压垮你的一切面前依然庆祝黑人的生活，是一种激进的抗议方式。你在街道上占据空间。你毫不妥协地跳舞和高喊。但你不要与警察产生纠缠。继续前行就好。但约翰不想再听这些了。
Let me ask a fucking question. When Breonna Taylor was slain in her bedroom, was she giving out Black joy? Was she listening to music? Was she bopping her fucking head? No, no music, it was just rings-- gunshots. Why the fuck are we giving them our Black joy? They don't deserve our Black joy. They deserve the Black rage we have, every ounce of it. This is war.
让我问个他妈的问题。当布伦娜·泰勒在卧室里被杀时，她在分享“黑人的快乐”吗？她在听音乐吗？她在点头吗？不，没有音乐，只有枪声。我们为什么要给他们分享我们的“黑人的快乐”？他们不配得到我们的快乐。他们应得的是我们心中的“黑人的愤怒”，每一分每一毫的愤怒。这是战争。
There was a truth to John's anger that was hard to look away from. I recognized his rage. When Marcus, my friend, was killed by the cops, I didn't realize how angry I was until I walked into a chicken spot on my block, and I saw a customer threatening to fight my favorite cashier. I didn't even know the cashier that well, but I wanted to beat the brakes off this customer for no good reason, other than he was a threat to somebody I knew, somebody I liked.
约翰的愤怒中有一种让人无法移开视线的真相。我认出了这种愤怒。当我的朋友马库斯被警察杀害时，我直到走进街区的一家炸鸡店看到顾客威胁要打我最喜欢的收银员时，才意识到自己有多愤怒。我甚至不太认识那个收银员，但我却想把那个顾客往死里揍，没有别的理由，只是因为他是某种我知道、我很喜欢的人的威胁。
But nothing happened. So I just wandered aimlessly around my block and considered walking into traffic. But I never did. I just swallowed my anger and pushed it somewhere I could never access it again. When I met John, he seemed to be at a similar crossroads-- swallow his anger or do something with it. And by now, I knew from listening to him that he's not the type to walk away from a fight.
但什么也没发生。于是我只是漫无目的地在街区徘徊，考虑着走进车流。但我从未那么做。我只是吞下愤怒，把它推到我永远无法触及的地方。当我见到约翰时，他似乎也站在类似的十字路口——吞下愤怒，还是用它做点什么。到目前为止，从他的话语中我知道，他不是那种会退缩的人。
The way you move and the way you use your anger, I don't know. It feels like maybe the anger helps somehow. There's something good about it. There's something that I could actually learn from it.
你的行事方式和使用愤怒的方式，我不知道。感觉也许这种愤怒在某种程度上是有帮助的。它有某种好处。有些东西我真的可以从中学习。
So what the anger does, it takes that person that is afraid and tells it, shut the hell up. Let's go. I think you not allowing yourself to continue to fight got you mad. And I think who you were mad at was not on anybody else but yourself, because you knew what you were doing was wrong. So you weren't mad-- you were upset with the police at what they did, hell yeah. But the person that you were really mad at was yourself because you were walking away from what you were believing in. You gave up on you.
愤怒的作用是，它能抓住那个恐惧的人并告诉他，闭嘴。我们走吧。我觉得你没允许自己继续战斗才让你愤怒。我觉得你愤怒的不是别人，而是你自己，因为你知道你所做的是错的。所以你并不生气——你对警察的行为感到失望，当然是的。但你真正生气的人是你自己，因为你背离了你的信仰。你放弃了你自己。
One day, at the end of one of our conversations in September, John invited me to a protest. Maybe he was trying to help me see something, or maybe he wanted to prove to me that he wasn't all talk. But he told me to meet him at a park in the Bronx the next day.
九月的一次谈话结束时，约翰邀请我去参加一场抗议。也许他是想帮我看到些什么，或者他想向我证明他不是光说不练。他让我第二天去布朗克斯的一个公园找他。
It's about 4:00 PM when I pull up. There's a small crowd gathered at the center of the park, no more than 100 people. And the first thing you hear when you're approaching the crowd is something like, if you're not comfortable being arrested, this is not the place for you.
下午4点左右我到了。公园中心聚集了一小群人，不超过100个。当你接近人群时，你听到的第一件事就是，如果你不想被捕，这里不适合你。
I know some of us are and might be. We don't like those fascists, but we know--
我知道我们中有些人是或者可能是。我们不喜欢那些法西斯，但我们知道——
It's not a Warriors protest. This one was organized by a couple other groups John's been spending more time with since his hit-and-run. They're protesters who are a little more willing to antagonize the cops. I find out from somebody what I already suspected. The goal of this protest is to march onto the George Washington Bridge and shut it down. There's a few Warriors who have shown up. But I don't see Derrick. He told me later that this was not his kind of protest.
这不是“战士”的抗议。这场是由约翰在肇事逃逸后花更多时间在一起的其他几个团体组织的。他们是更愿意对抗警察的抗议者。我从某人那里证实了我预感到的事。这场抗议的目标是游行到乔治·华盛顿大桥并将其封锁。有几个“战士”出现了。但我没看到德里克。他后来告诉我这不是他那种抗议。
I said, John, I don't think the Warriors should participate, and I cannot participate. I think you like the idea of taking a bridge because it sounds cool. I didn't hear any demands. I didn't hear an endgame. I didn't know what a resolution was.
我说，约翰，我不觉得“战士”们应该参加，我也不能参加。我觉得你喜欢夺桥这个主意，因为它听起来很酷。我没听到什么诉求。我没听到什么终局。我不知道解决方案是什么。
There may not have been a specific set of demands, but there was an endgame. And it seems like the cops know about this plan to take the bridge, too. Because just a few feet away from where we're standing, patrol cars and vans are starting to pull up to follow the march, a long row of red and blue lights flashing down the street for blocks. I start looking around the crowd for John, but I spot Chi instead.
可能没有一套具体的诉求，但有一个终局。看起来警察也知道这个占领大桥的计划。因为离我们站的地方仅几英尺远的地方，巡逻车和面包车开始靠近以跟随游行，长长一排红蓝警灯闪烁着横跨几个街区。我开始在人群中寻找约翰，却发现了Chi。
You like my collared shirt today? Do I look like a politician today?
你喜欢我今天的衬衫吗？我今天看起来像个政治家吗？
You do look like a politician today.
你今天看起来确实像个政治家。
Nice.
不错。
In his sweater/collared shirt combo, Chi tells me he's been asked to give a speech. He walks up onto a makeshift podium in front of the crowd.
穿着毛衣配衬衫，Chi告诉我他被邀请发表演讲。他走上人群前方的一个简易讲台。
How are we going to change the course of this war, the course of this battle against criminal injustice in New York City, criminal injustice--
我们将如何改变这场战争的进程，这场对抗纽约市刑事不公的战斗的进程，刑事不公——
Like John, Chi also believes that they're in a war. But he believes it's a war best fought through legislation, from inside the walls of city council, once he wins-- not on the George Washington Bridge.
像约翰一样，Chi也相信他们正在战争中。但他相信这场战争最好通过立法来打，一旦他获胜，就从市议会的墙内打，而不是在乔治·华盛顿大桥上。
Our ancestors have fought so hard for the right to vote.
我们的祖先为了投票权奋斗得太艰难了。
Once he finishes his speech, Chi gets ready to leave.
演讲结束后，Chi准备离开。
So you're about to leave?
所以你要走了？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
Why don't you want to stay?
为什么不想留下来？
Because I have other things to do today. I have other campaign matters to attend to today.
因为我今天还有别的事要做。我今天还有竞选事项要处理。
All right, man. Be safe.
好吧，伙计。保重。
And tomorrow. Yeah. Yeah, you, too. The cops are already out here today. You can tell that the energy is a little different here in the Bronx in terms of just the police that have already arrived. My power is outside of those bars. I will not be arrested. I won't. There's some of-- OK, there's some people here-- I'm not snitching-- in bulletproof vests. It's not my energy. I can't be doing that.
明天见。是啊，你也是。警察今天已经在这儿了。你能感觉到在布朗克斯，就警察已经到达的数量而言，气氛有点不同。我的力量在这些铁栏之外。我不会被捕的。我不会。这里有些人——我不是打小报告——穿着防弹背心。这不是我的能量。我不能搞那个。
This did not calm my nerves, because Chi was right. What the hell was I doing out here? But before I can think about it too hard, I finally spot John. He's dressed in all black-- black pants, black long-sleeved shirt, black Kaepernick jersey, black ski mask, and a black bulletproof vest. Just as Chi's about to leave, John calls him over. They chat, they hug for a second, and afterwards, I walk over to John.
这并没有让我的神经平复，因为Chi是对的。我在这里干什么鬼？但在我仔细思考之前，我终于看到了约翰。他全身黑衣——黑裤子、黑色长袖衬衫、黑色卡佩尼克球衣、黑色滑雪面罩和黑色防弹背心。就在Chi准备离开时，约翰把他叫了过去。他们交谈，抱了一下，随后，我走向约翰。
I'm not surprised myself.
我没把自己感到惊讶。
What's up, man? How are you doing?
怎么样，伙计？你好吗？
Disappointed.
很失望。
Why?
为什么？
I'm proud that everybody's out here that wanted to come out here because it just shows me who has heart. But then it just shows how many people are cappin', how many people are just running their mouth. I'm not an asshole. I love my squad. But where's Chi now?
我为每一个想来的人都来了感到自豪，因为这向我展示了谁有胆量。但这也显示了多少人在吹牛，多少人只是信口雌黄。我不是混蛋。我爱我的小队。但Chi现在在哪儿？
Not long after, the protest starts to move.
没多久，抗议开始移动。
It's important that we keep it tight and that we keep it structured. All right? Who's with me?
重要的是我们保持紧凑和有组织。好吗？谁跟我一起？
[CHEERING]
[欢呼]
If you're with me, put your fist in the air! If you're with me, put your fist in the air.
如果跟我一起，把拳头举向空中！如果跟我一起，把拳头举向空中。
The George Washington Bridge is a major revenue source for the city. The protesters believe if they shut it down, they'll cost the city money, get a lot of news coverage, and a lot of attention for the movement, too. As we march from the park into the streets of the Bronx, John moved through the small crowd, checking in on people. After a while, we finally reached the George Washington Bridge. And when John sees it, his eyes seem to light up through the holes in a ski mask.
乔治·华盛顿大桥是城市的主要收入来源。抗议者认为如果他们封锁它，就会让城市损失金钱，获得大量新闻报道，也能为运动带来关注。当我们从公园游行进入布朗克斯街道时，约翰在人群中穿梭，查看大家的情况。过了一会儿，我们终于到达了乔治·华盛顿大桥。当约翰看到它时，他的眼睛似乎在滑雪面罩的孔后闪闪发光。
This is the bridge.
这就是大桥。
Oh, shit.
哦，该死。
Watch this magic. Watch. Watch this beautiful shit.
看这魔法。看。看这美妙的狗屁东西。
I'd never seen the George Washington Bridge on foot, all 4,760 feet of it just towering right in front of us. I look over at John, and he's having a moment.
我从没徒步走过乔治·华盛顿大桥，全长4760英尺，就在我们面前耸立。我看向约翰，他正在享受这一刻。
Oh, yes! Oh, yes! My heart is racing, and I feel so good! Yo, I feel like a-- I feel like an orgasm. I feel like I'm about to hoop-- ah-- all over the NYPD, baby!
哦，是的！哦，是的！我的心跳加速，感觉太棒了！伙计，我觉得像个——我觉得像是在——啊——在那群纽约警察身上高潮了，宝贝！
For too long, we're taking half steps. This is a full measure. Are you ready?
太久以来，我们走的都是小步子。这是一个完整的举措。准备好了吗？
Yeah!
准备好了！
Then let's go.
那就走吧。
John rushes to the on-ramp with the other protesters. They grab giant construction cones and place them in front of traffic. And pretty soon, the whole upper deck of the bridge, eight lanes wide, from New York to New Jersey, there's no cars-- just this small group of protesters suspended above the Hudson River, standing shoulder to shoulder, arms linked, hyped about what they're accomplishing. I find John darting around the crowd.
约翰和抗议者们冲向坡道。他们抓起巨大的施工路锥放在车流前。很快，大桥整个上层，八车道宽，从纽约到新泽西，没有车——只有这群挂在哈德逊河上方、肩并肩、手挽手的抗议者，为他们所完成的事情而兴奋不已。我发现约翰在人群中穿梭。
How does it feel, bro?
感觉如何，兄弟？
We the few! We the few are many! That's how I feel. Look at the power we have! And none of our brothers and sisters came out to support us! None!
我们是少数！我们少数人就是多数！这就是我的感觉。看看我们拥有的力量！而且我们那些兄弟姐妹一个都没出来支持我们！一个都没有！
John and the other activists keep the upper level of the bridge shut down for about an hour. The whole time we're up there, the police are nearby, watching, looking annoyed. They had the bridge, but what these protesters really wanted was to show how violent the cops can be. They want to prove the police will act with impunity, hopefully get it caught on camera, it goes viral, and they make their point.
约翰和其他活动人士将大桥上层封锁了大约一小时。我们在那儿的整个时间，警察都在附近盯着，一脸厌恶。他们占领了大桥，但这些抗议者真正想要的是展示警察有多暴力。他们想证明警察会肆无忌惮地行动，希望这被摄像头拍下，流传开来，以此表达他们的观点。
After 45 minutes, the cops finally move them off the bridge relatively peacefully. But unsatisfied, the group marches towards a nearby precinct. And the whole way there, more cops start to appear from the dark, dressed in riot gear right behind us. When the group gets to the precinct, there's more cops waiting out front, too.
45分钟后，警察最终相对和平地将他们从大桥上驱离。但意犹未尽，该团体向附近的警察局游行。在那条路上，更多警察从黑暗中出现，穿着防暴装备跟在我们身后。当该团体到达警察局时，前面也有更多警察在等着。
This is where we stand. This is where we stand. We got it jammed up. This is where we stand.
这就是我们的立场。这就是我们的立场。我们把这儿堵上了。这就是我们的立场。
At that point, the cops have had enough. They gave a quick dispersal warning. Not long enough for people to actually respond to, but long enough to say they did it. I got the sense that they knew what this was, too. So they gave them what they came for. They started charging towards us and violently snatching people out of the crowd.
那一刻，警察受够了。他们迅速发出了驱散警告。时间短到人们无法真正回应，但足够让他们说自己已经警告过。我感觉到他们也知道这是怎么回事。所以他们给了他们想要的结果。他们开始向我们冲锋，暴力地将人从人群中拽出来。
This is the New York City Police Department. You are unlawfully in the roadway and obstructing vehicular traffic.
这里是纽约警察局。你们在路面上非法滞留并阻碍车辆交通。
We all started running away. And in the chaos of bodies bumping into each other, I tripped over somebody trying to escape. I quickly got back up and backed away from the crowd to look at what was happening from a safer distance. And some people were crying. Others were screaming in pain. And John was still darting around the crowd. It definitely felt like a war, and I think some people didn't realize that's what they were signing up for.
我们都开始逃跑。在肢体碰撞的混乱中，我被试图逃跑的人绊倒了。我很快站起来，退到离人群更安全的地方看发生了什么。有些人哭了。其他人痛苦地尖叫。而约翰还在人群中穿梭。这确实感觉像一场战争，我想有些人没意识到那是他们所签名的内容。
I saw John walk up to a couple who were frozen with fear and crying in each other's arms, and he told them to go home, to get out of here. The night ended with at least six people arrested. One of them was a good friend of John's. I understood then why Derrick didn't show up for this and why Chi left. It all felt pointless. When I spoke to John later, I told him that.
我看到约翰走到一对冻结在恐惧中并抱头痛哭的恋人面前，告诉他们回家，离开这里。当晚结束时，至少有六人被捕。其中一个是约翰的好朋友。我当时理解了德里克为什么没来，为什么Chi离开了。这一切看起来毫无意义。后来我跟约翰谈起时，我说了。
When we went out there, by the end of it, people were trampling over each other, dog. People were literally crying. I don't know. It just didn't seem like the anger was useful in that moment. It seemed like it was more destructive than anything.
当我们出去时，最后人们在那儿相互踩踏，伙计。人们真的哭了。我不知道。只是觉得那时的愤怒并没有什么用。看起来比什么都更具破坏性。
You didn't see it then.
你那时没看见。
Say it again?
再说一遍？
You didn't see it then.
你那时没看见。
John tells me the goal here was to expose the police and their brutality, that this is how they will make sure their message is heard.
约翰告诉我，这里的目标是揭露警察及其暴行，这就是他们确保自己的信息被听到的方式。
Isn't that the point, to prove how disgusting the system is? I am looking at the goal. The goal for me is abolishing the police, tearing down the whole system. So, in order to have everybody see why, because there's people that don't see why. Let me show you why. Keep exposing them. Keep exposing them. Keep exposing them until everybody sees.
难道目标不是证明这个制度有多恶心吗？我看着目标。对我的目标是废除警察，拆掉整个体制。所以，为了让所有人看到为什么，因为有些人看不到。让我告诉你为什么。继续揭露他们。继续揭露他们。继续揭露他们，直到所有人都能看到。
I don't know. I just hope that there's a more safer way to do it.
我不知道。我只是希望有一种更安全的方式。
There's not. And if there was, we would have gone about it that way. But every time that we go safely about it, nothing happens. There is no safe way of doing this. I'm sorry.
没有。如果有，我们早就那样做了。但每一次我们以安全的方式行事时，什么都不会发生。没有安全的做法，伙计。对不起。
I did see the thing John wanted me to see. I saw that the police were being unnecessarily violent. I'd experienced that at lots of protests. But I also saw this other thing. I saw John telling people to get to safety and trying to pull protesters out of the grasp of cops, but he couldn't save everyone. He couldn't be everywhere at once. If you are running headfirst into a war, you're going to lose people. But I guess we're losing people either way.
我确实看到了约翰想让我看到的东西。我看到了警察正在无理取闹地暴力行事。我在许多抗议活动中都经历过。但我也看到了另一面。我看到约翰告诉人们注意安全，试图把抗议者从警察手中拉出来，但他无法拯救所有人。他不可能同时出现在任何地方。如果你一头扎进战争，你就会失去人。但我想我们无论如何都在失去人。
The Warriors felt like John was crossing the line they'd set as a group at the beginning of all this. For a nonviolent group, John was flirting too much with chaos and vengeance. They told him they were worried about him and encouraged him to take better care of his mental health because they knew John suffered from depression, and he was off his meds. They had a series of disagreements about how to move forward with John. But eventually, they decided to just air it all out on a Zoom call. Here's Derrick.
“战士”们觉得约翰越过了他们作为一个团体在这一切开始时划下的底线。作为一个非暴力团体，约翰在混沌和复仇的边缘试探得太多了。他们告诉他，他们为他担心，并鼓励他更好地照顾自己的心理健康，因为他们知道约翰患有抑郁症，而且他没吃药。他们就如何与约翰继续合作进行了一系列争论。但最终，他们决定在 Zoom 会议上摊开来说。这是德里克。
He literally said, I want every single person to say their issue with me back to back. I won't interrupt you because I want to hear all of this. And I want to know how to respond.
他直接说，我希望每个人都依次说出对我有什么意见。我不会打断你，因为我想听听所有这些。我想知道该如何回应。
And immediately, it just turned into an attack on me. It didn't feel like they wanted to keep me. It felt like they were just trying to find a way to out me.
立刻，这变成了一场对我的攻击。感觉他们不是想留住我。感觉他们只是在找方法把我踢出去。
What was the first thing they said?
他们说的第一件事是什么？
Kiara started. It was she doesn't trust me because of-- I'm a liability or something like that. I'm a risk or some shit.
Kiara 先说的。她说她不信任我，因为——我是个负担什么的。我是个风险之类。
I told John, I said I personally would not like you in the group anymore because of your actions. Personally, we all love John personally. But when you see kind of the shift in character and a shift in beliefs, we had to come to an agreement. Like, OK, what's best for the group?
我告诉约翰，我说我个人因为你的行为不希望你再留在组里。我们个人都爱约翰。但当你看到性格和信仰的转变时，我们不得不达成协议。比如，好吧，什么对团体最好？
The Warriors told John that if he was going to stay in the group, he'd need to commit to three things. First, that he'd make his mental health a priority. Second, he'd need to pledge his loyalty to the group. And third-- maybe the biggest point-- that he'd need to commit to being non-violent.
“战士”们告诉约翰，如果他要留在组里，需要承诺三件事。第一，他要优先考虑心理健康。第二，他要宣誓忠于团体。第三——也许是最重要的一点——他要承诺非暴力。
But he didn't want to really address our three demands. And he couldn't. He couldn't commit to them.
但他真的不想回应我们的三项要求。他做不到。他不能承诺那些。
And I just couldn't focus. I was mad, and I was angry, and it wasn't supposed to go that way. It was supposed to be something really, really calm. Really, everybody talk respectfully. But nobody was doing that.
我当时就无法集中注意力了。我疯了，我很愤怒，这不该是这样的。这本该是真的很平静。确实，大家尊重地谈话。但没人那么做。
Finally, the Warriors decided to call a vote on whether John should be allowed to stay in the group or not. They voted no. Later in his apartment, John is still replaying how things went down.
最后，“战士”们决定就约翰是否应被允许留在组里进行投票。他们投了反对票。后来在他的公寓里，约翰还在回味事情是怎么发生的。
I-- this is fucking-- like, what's that shit called? Survival island or some shit like that? I got voted out. Like, what the fuck? [LAUGHS] That shit was unreal, son. It was unreal for me.
我——这他妈是——这叫什么来着？生存岛还是什么破玩意？我被投票踢出局了。这他妈是什么鬼？[笑] 这太不真实了，孩子。对我来说太不真实了。
He cycles through a bunch of emotions, laughing, shouting about it. On his bedroom wall, I see this black and white photo of the Warriors together from the beginning.
他反复经历着各种情绪，大笑，大喊大叫。在他的卧室墙上，我看到那张“战士”们最初在一起的黑白照片。
It was a family. I learned that it was like my family. I spoke to Derrick. Yo, Derrick, I love you, man. Don't get it twisted. I didn't like how the shit went down, but I love you. It just hurts. It hurts. They betrayed me, bro. [EXHALES] It's been hard, man. Yo, those Warriors, man, they betrayed me, man. They betrayed me, son. They left me out there in the cold to rot, bro. Did me dirt.
那是家人。我知道这就像我的家人。我跟德里克谈过。嘿，德里克，我爱你，伙计。别误会。我不喜欢事情的发展方式，但我爱你。只是很痛。很痛。他们背叛了我，兄弟。[呼气] 一直很艰难，伙计。那些“战士”，伙计，他们背叛了我，伙计。他们背叛了我，孩子。他们把我留在冷风中腐烂，兄弟。真缺德。
Ever since my friend Marcus was killed, I've been sitting with this question-- what am I supposed to do with this weight? With the Warriors, I think I had this expectation that when police violence lands in your lap, there's only one right way to deal with it. I thought with John, Chi, and Derrick, I might finally figure out what that one way was. But the three of them have each landed in three very different places. John is still running headfirst towards cops at protests and getting arrested, now with a different group of people. He's not playing it safe, and he's OK with that.
自从我的朋友马库斯被杀后，我一直被这个问题困扰——我该怎么处理这块重量？对于“战士”，我想我曾有过这种期望，即当警察暴力降临时，只有一种正确方式来处理它。我想有了约翰、Chi和德里克，我可能终于能弄清楚那唯一的方式是什么了。但他们三个人每个人都走到了三个非常不同的终点。约翰依然在抗议中迎着警察冲锋并被捕，现在和一群不同的人在一起。他没想过安全行事，但他对此没意见。
Chi is nine months into his political campaign. I've gone out canvassing with him. Just the other day, I watched him basically obliterate his opponents at a debate.
Chi的政治竞选已经九个月了。我曾跟他出去挨家挨户拉票。就在几天前，我看着他在一场辩论中摧毁了他的对手。
Do you feel like you're becoming a better politician?
你觉得你正在成为一个更好的政治家吗？
I don't like to consider myself a politician. I would say I'm more of a public advocate, and I'm running to be a public advocate. I'm a candidate for public advocacy.
我不喜欢认为自己是政治家。我会说我更像是一个公共倡导者，我竞选是为了成为公共倡导者。我是公共倡导的候选人。
So the answer is yes, you've become a better politician.
所以答案是肯定的，你已经成为了一个更好的政治家。
Does it sound like I have?
听起来像吗？
You just sidestepped my question and put your own rhetoric out there in the most seamless way. So I think--
你刚才避开了我的问题，并以最无缝的方式表达了你自己的那一套。所以我认为——
I've become a better public advocate. That's the right answer.
我成为了一个更好的公共倡导者。那是正确的答案。
OK.
好的。
Derrick is still going to protests all the time with the Warriors and Chi, but he's grown to be a high-profile activist now with a huge platform. He's now working with places like Amnesty International and Reebok to bring attention to police overreach. He's found his life's work. All three of them have figured out what I still haven't.
德里克依然经常和“战士”们以及Chi一起去抗议，但他现在已经成长为一名拥有庞大平台的高调活动人士。他现在与国际特赦组织和锐步等机构合作，以引起对警察越权的关注。他找到了毕生的事业。他们三个人都弄清楚了我还没弄明白的事。
On Martin Luther King Day, there was a protest at Barclays Center in Brooklyn. And everyone was there-- Chi, John, and Derrick. By now, tensions had cooled, and they were all smiling and talking to each other, just catching up. At some point, dancing broke out, as it always does. People formed a circle, and Chi got in the middle for a second and hit a few moves. I looked off to the side, and Derrick was joining in. When I turned around, I couldn't believe it. There was John, getting low, dancing along with them.
马丁·路德·金纪念日那天，布鲁克林巴克莱中心有一场抗议。每个人都在那里——Chi、约翰和德里克。到那时，紧张局势已经缓解，他们都在微笑并交谈，只是在叙旧。某个时刻，舞蹈开始了，一如往常。人们围成一个圈，Chi走到中间跳了几下。我看向旁边，德里克也加入了。当我转过身时，我简直不敢相信。约翰也在那里，压低身体，和他们一起跳着舞。
I'm always happy to see them together and enjoying themselves like this. I'm also haunted by this other thought. It's this. Think of all the other things these talented, creative people could have been spending their enormous energy on. How far could Chi have taken his love for fashion if he'd never seen that George Floyd video? What could John be doing with all the time he's been spending going to neurological appointments for injuries from being beaten up by cops? What if Derrick's apartment could have just stayed a party pad and didn't have to be the site of a police siege? Who could these three men have been if their paths weren't defined by these tragic events?
我总是很高兴看到他们在一起并像这样享受时光。我也被另一个想法所困扰。是这个。想想这些才华横溢、富有创造力的人本可以把巨大的精力花在所有其他事情上。如果Chi从未看到那个乔治·弗洛伊德的视频，他对自己时尚的热爱能走多远？约翰把所有去神经科预约治疗被警察殴打造成的伤害的时间用在别处会怎样？如果德里克的公寓只是一间派对公寓，而不是警察围困的现场会怎样？如果这三个人的道路没有被这些悲惨事件所定义，他们本来会成为谁？
That day, they're dancing. And for a moment, they're just people. Chi is just a 22-year-old dude with his friends. John isn't angry, and Derrick gets to just be there for the both of them. I think I've been paralyzed by this question of how to respond to police violence. Because for me, every answer feels like another loss. Toward the end of the night, we march to City Hall. Then, the police started violently arresting people. That ended things-- the way they always end.
那天，他们跳着舞。在那一刻，他们只是人。Chi只是一个和朋友在一起的22岁小伙子。约翰不生气，而德里克得以就在他们身边。我想我被如何回应警察暴力这个问题给困住了。因为对我来说，每一个答案都感觉是另一次损失。夜幕快降临时，我们游行到市政厅。然后，警察开始暴力逮捕人。那结束了一切——就像他们总是结束的方式那样。
[SHOUTING]
[喊叫声]
Saidu Tejan-Thomas Jr. You can find Saidu's show Resistance on Spotify or wherever you get your podcasts.
小赛杜·特詹-托马斯。你可以在 Spotify 或任何你获取播客的地方找到赛杜的节目《抵抗》。
[MUSIC - "FIGHT!" BY WYATT WADDELL]
[音乐 - 怀亚特·沃德尔的《战斗！》]
Our program was produced today by Chana Joffe Walt. The people who put our show together today include Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Hilary Elkins, Damien Graef, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ari Saperstein, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Laura Starcheski, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Special thanks today to Anna Carlsen, Richard Symister, Eileen and Bobby Berry, Sarah McVeigh, Wallace Mack, and the entire Resistance team.
我们的节目今天由 Chana Joffe Walt 制作。今天共同完成我们节目的人包括本·卡尔霍恩、达娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德、希拉里·埃尔金斯、达米恩·格拉夫、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、阿里·萨珀斯坦、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普、劳拉·斯塔切斯基、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。我们的管理编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜勒拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。今天特别感谢安娜·卡尔森、理查德·西米斯特、艾琳和鲍比·贝里、莎拉·麦克维、华莱士·麦克以及整个《抵抗》团队。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks to my boss, Ira Glass. He has an instruction manual for anyone who hosts the show. It's confusing how it starts, just all caps.
我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们超过700集节目的档案。《美国生活》由 PRX（公共广播交易所）传送到公共广播电台。感谢我的老板，伊拉·格拉斯。他为每一位主持节目的人准备了一本说明手册。手册开头就让人困惑，全是全大写字母。
There is no safe way of doing this. I'm sorry.
没有安全的做法。对不起。
I'm Emanuele Berry. Ira Glass will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是埃马纽埃尔·贝里。伊拉·格拉斯下周会回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "FIGHT!" BY WYATT WADDELL]
[音乐 - 怀亚特·沃德尔的《战斗！》]